what's going on guys this is rob and
eternals officially comes out today at
the time that we're recording this video
and i'm going to see it at 6 00 p.m
tonight with my girl so uh if you guys
are curious about my review on the
eternals then make sure you guys check
out geek culture explain tomorrow
because that's where i will be talking
about it having said that in this video
i want to talk about the deviance and i
want to do a little bit of a deep dive
here right and there's two different
reasons why we're doing that one is
because it'll just provide more meat and
potatoes for the video and two when it
comes to making a video explaining the
deviants you have the deviants as a race
themselves which are largely irrelevant
after the fourth host and then you have
like crow of the deviants who is really
the only relevant deviant uh in the
history of the entire race right so we
might do a video on ham at a separate
point in time let me know in the in the
comment section if you guys want to see
a video on crow specifically but uh the
deviant race itself is really really
cool and they're really significant it's
just marvel never really did a whole lot
with them right so we've kind of talked
about this history of like the eternals
the deviants and mutants and all that
kind of stuff over the course of the the
life of the youtube channel but
something i want to do here is something
that we never did in our video on
mutants and we never really did in our
video on eternals i want to talk about
the nature of the experimentation that
was done with regards to the deviants
that actually turned them into who they
are so something i want to clarify here
is that the name deviant is not unique
to earth right that's not simply just
referring to that race as it exists on
earth that's a general term given to any
race whose genes were modified basically
by xeron the tester to reflect the goal
that he was achieving which is
destabilize genes so to give you guys
perspective here the name deviant is
like the name politician right like here
on earth when you use the name
politician you're not referring to a
particular person you're referring to a
role a person plays they are a
politician those people are politicians
right that kind of a thing and so
deviance follows the exact same way a
really good example of this is the race
of scrolls which you guys are probably
aware of from the marvel cinematic
universe and the captain marvel films
that when the celestials showed up on
scrollos the homeworld of the scrolls
like 100 million years ago that they did
exactly what they did on earth they took
a portion of that race and they modified
their genes so that you basically had
the eternal scrolls the deviant scrolls
and then baseline scrolls that had no
real special powers but at some future
point in time those powers would
manifest what happened on scrollos is
the deviants wiped out the eternals and
the baseline scrolls and so all you had
left were deviant scrolls and that's why
when you look at the race as it exists
now you see these kind of hallmark
traits these things that seemingly span
from one race to the other based on the
experiments of the celestials for
example thanos is technically an eternal
however he possesses the deviant gene
and that's why he has that crazy looking
chin that makes him look like he's
similar to the race of scrolls because
at the end of the day the deviants all
share a kind of experimental archetype
that more or less seem to result in them
looking something similar to each other
across the entirety of the universe now
why that's the case we don't really know
we have no idea why the celestials do
what they do we just know that they do
that kind of stuff but that's an example
of where an entire race of deviants had
basically conquered the world on which
they live now getting into the meat and
potatoes of this and the important
explanation about all this stuff the
deviants are wildly interesting right
they're really really really really
fascinating so one of the things that we
talked about in our eternals and our
mutants explained videos and celestials
videos things like that is that the
celestials visited the earth about a
million years ago and started
experimenting on people now this kind of
early primate man sort of thing they
were referred to as the wanderers right
kind of the missing link between primate
man and modern man and the idea is that
they were split into three groups now
this kind of splitting up was done by a
celestial named gamanon the gatherer but
you had zero on the tester and then you
had nazar the calculator and then you
had oneegg the prober nazar the
calculator is the name of the celestial
that created the eternals and oneg the
prober is the name of the celestial that
created basically mutants or at least
set things up so mutants would emerge at
some future point in time zero on the
tester is the one that we care about now
we don't really know much about this guy
like most of the celestials we don't
really know much about the nature of
xero on the tester outside of the fact
that he's a celestial he can modify
genes do virtually anything he wants to
and he's just uber powerful right that's
really all we know he kind of falls rank
and file with the way you normally see
celestials but the purpose here as he
done on so many worlds was to simply
destabilize genes right to create
unchecked mutations to kind of defy
evolution and this is an exceedingly
important thing right because when it
comes to evolution evolutionary change
is usually a response to an environment
so say for example the surface of the
earth became uninhabitable for any
number of reasons climate change nuclear
war i don't know like galactus comes to
earth and just farts and it just lingers
for like a million years whatever the
case happens to be
right we as humans may end up descending
underground right we'll just take up
residence in underground caves and
caverns what will happen if we spend
enough time there is that over a series
of generations our biological structure
will begin to change to adapt to that
environment so maybe we gain enhanced
eyesight so we can see in the dark or
maybe eyesight's abandoned in its
entirety because we don't need it to see
in the dark and our other senses begin
to expand our senses of hearing our
senses of touch different things along
those lines perhaps we even develop some
form of echolocation but that takes
generations upon generations upon
generations based on that quick and
sudden change to our environment as it
exists assuming that our environment
here on the surface largely remains
unchanged that there wouldn't really be
a huge differentiation between humanity
as we exist now and humanity as it
exists in like 10 generations with
deviance it doesn't work that way
there's no such thing as a quote-unquote
normal deviant as there is with like a
quote-unquote normal human right eyes on
the front of our face so we have depth
perception five fingers on each hand
five toes on each foot sentience higher
level thinking the kind of traits that
we would describe to what we call a
normal human being that doesn't exist
among the deviants that what deviants
have is a kind of window or what
deviants have described as being an
acceptable range of traits among their
race and so what you got here in the
early days of the deviant race and this
is particularly important is that
following their creation it was really
of one at least from an immediate sense
trying to understand how their race
would form and how their race would
function what kind of empire it would
look like things like that you saw a
kind of priesthood arriving and what
they would do is that in creating this
range of acceptable traits that they
would take anybody who was deemed to be
outside of that range of acceptable
traits and they would either execute
them or they would exile them and there
was no arguing it right there was no in
between there now this is on top of what
was basically the the violent nature of
deviance and the fact that even among a
deviant family there would be a sort of
coldness and callousness there in a lot
of ways it was kind of every man for
himself there wasn't really any
unification among the race which is one
of the significant roles that crow
played among the deviants was actually
unifying them in a way that just hadn't
really been done before but outside of
that priesthood concept and getting rid
of those individuals who were deemed as
mutates because their mutations were so
extreme even for the deviant race and
their exile or executions or individuals
who simply hadn't mutated enough you had
the deviants waging war against the
eternals now a lot of this was just done
for dominion right just the the person
to run the world at least the the
attempts that the deviants had and for
the most part they controlled a huge
portion of it right because deviants
evolved so incredibly fast in the sense
that you might have a deviant who is
moderately intelligent then their
offspring is just a genius level
intellect or you might have a deviant
that has super strength and then their
offspring has shape-shifting super
strength and the ability to fly or
something along those lines right i'm
just arbitrarily grabbing you know
character traits or or powers to just
kind of illustrate a point here but
because you would see such extreme and
rapid changes among their race that what
you found is that deviants far
outstripped the capabilities of baseline
humanity now the eternals never really
had to contend with that because the
eternals were engineered to be perfect
beings so their knowledge of technology
science all that kind of stuff was light
years ahead of humanity but deviants
were catching up very very fast the
reason why this matters is because where
i previously this is actually a mistake
that i've been making over the years i
always thought lumeria in terms of where
the deviants resided was the capital
city of atlantis it's actually not it
was their kingdom in the pacific that
atlantis was its own thing out there you
know in the the atlantic ocean but the
the deviants themselves had basically
ruled the world from their capital city
of lumeria now a lot of this happened
because the eternals just didn't care
right they were they had totally
abandoned their role of safeguarding
humanity they were just kind of out
there doing their own thing giving no
real thought to what was happening
around them and so this allowed the
deviants with their rapid intelligence
growth based on their evolutionary
progress happening so incredibly fast to
actually enslave the whole of humanity
as it existed at the time the only safe
haven that you had there was atlantis
and the reason why atlantis was a safe
haven is because this was a trading hub
it was neutral territory right it was
the only real place where deviants and
eternals and humans at least those
humans who hadn't been conquered could
live without fear of being you know
executed or or enslaved or something
along those lines right it's neutral
ground nobody harms anybody right
everybody just kind of does their own
thing it's a safe haven now while it's
never explicitly stated in marvel comics
the enslavement of humanity by the
deviants had actually set humanity back
a pretty good period of time and the
reason why is because while human beings
with traditional powers hadn't really
manifested and if they did marvel's
never really revealed it to us there had
to be individuals out there that had
enhanced intellects but if they did have
those nothing ever came of it because
baseline humanity was used as a labor
force they weren't taught to read they
weren't taught to write none of that
kind of stuff right they were taught to
go there and and smash those rocks and
keep doing it until i tell you to stop
right that's basically how they were
used now as we've mentioned in previous
videos the first coming of the
celestials to modify the genes of the
wonders to create the deviants and the
eternals and the baseline humans that
this was referred to as the first host
the second host was the celestials
coming to basically check up on their
experimentation now the big thing about
this is that with the deviants having
conquered so much of the world basically
everything outside of atlantis and the
various territories that were ran by the
eternals but also warring with the
eternals in an effort to attain the
eternals lands and destroy the eternals
in their entirety when the celestials
showed back up they were pissed now some
of this had to do with the eternals
abandoning their role of safeguarding
humanity and some of it had to do with
the fact that the deviants had actually
attacked the celestials because they saw
them as a credible threat trying to
stand in the way of their ability to
rule the world the reality is the
celestials were angry because their
particular interest here with this
experiment was baseline humans what
would they become what would they be
capable of that was really the main meat
and potatoes here right to see the end
result of this baseline gene
experimentation coming to fruition in
whatever form it took and the deviants
enslaving humanity had basically halted
that and the eternals doing nothing to
stop humanity's enslavement and allowing
the deviants to enslave them in the
first place had pissed off the
celestials even more and so what you saw
here is what was referred to as the
great cataclysm and despite the
deviant's higher level of intelligence
beyond humanity allowing them to achieve
advanced weaponry advanced technology
things along those lines and despite the
fact that humanity was still relatively
primitive this basically led to the
deviant capital city of lumeria being
totally eliminated to the point that
most every single deviant across the
world was destroyed where previously
deviants had existed in the millions at
that point they've been reduced down to
a few thousand now this is particularly
important and the reason why is because
following this great cataclysm the
eternals were instructed by the
celestials to ensure the safety of
humanity but not to interfere with
humanity so if they had to go into human
cities and do anything they had to blend
in no one could know the eternals
existed the deviants kind of learned
their lesson right so they ended up just
taking off underground and it largely
remained there ever since but this is
marvel's way of explaining how it is
that one just these super advanced
pieces of technology have just kind of
been discovered around the world with no
real explanation of how they existed but
more so than that the great cataclysm
was offered as an explanation to
basically illustrate why it is the world
could be so technologically advanced
under the rule of the deviants and then
suddenly seem to start from zero because
with humanity not understanding any of
what they were seeing with regards to
the technology that the deviants had in
their possession that when the great
catechism took place that the eternals
seemingly vanished and the deviants went
underground the world belonged to
humanity now and so it basically started
over now following that one thing to
know about the deviants you had a few
things here and there you had a few
instances you know some conflicts and
stuff like that that happened but as an
entirety of a race they never really
mattered right i mean you did kind of
have a truce that was struck between the
uh the deviants and the eternals and the
in baseline humans and what was referred
to as the damocles foundation of course
they were created back in x-force issue
number 79 in 1998 and were based out of
portland oregon but even they weren't
necessarily a true unification i mean
they were but it was more of one of
these things where they believe that the
dropping of the atomic bomb had begun an
age where it essentially just
fast-tracked humanity destroying itself
and so in an effort to prevent that from
happening what they intended to do was
actually create a race of super beings
that would basically rule the world and
would end all war right it's better that
humanity rule under what some would
define as oppression than see the whole
of humanity wiped out and so because of
that the dammit police foundation of
course ran into conflict with shield and
things like operation zero tolerance you
know led by bastian and so on but all in
all the race of deviants following the
great cataclysm well i take that back
okay so one of the things that happened
during charles noff's eternal run is
that you actually ended up learning that
the deviants had worshipped the
celestials but when the celestials
initiated the great cataclysm the
deviants ultimately abandoned
worshipping the celestials as a whole
and then upon discovery of the dreaming
celestial had basically made this
declaration that they believed the
dreaming celestia was the one that they
should worship and the reason for this
is that while the other celestials out
there had served a purpose insofar as
creating the eternals or the deviants or
baseline humans that tiamu had actually
used his power to create some unique
beings but the eternals had actually
believed that tiamou was responsible for
their creation now that's not accurate
the way it actually played out is that
in the early days during the second host
when the great cataclysm was being
initiated that because the world had
demonstrated that it was basically a
world ran by the deviants that what was
supposed to happen is the world was
going to be cleansed by the celestials
themselves the energy would be sent to
the fulcrum who is basically the being
that all the celestials serve and then
it would be sent to the horde which is
basically the antithesis of the
celestials it's kind of a loose
definition here or a loose assignment
here but the celestials would kind of
represent good and the horde would sort
of represent evil and so if a world
basically is more deviant than it is
anything else it would be what you would
call an evil world now again those are
loose terms right they're not absolute
constructs but that's what was supposed
to happen instead because irish and the
judge had judged against the deviants
and simply initiated a what was almost a
complete calling of the deviance that he
moved the dreaming celestial had
attacked ereshan the judge believing
that he was basically malfunctioning
this led to the other celestials
attacking tiamou the dreaming celestial
and then imprisoning him in earth but
over the years the story of tiamou the
dreaming celestial trying to save the
deviants turned into tiamou the dreaming
celestial created the deviants and so
that kind of change in mythology over
the years led to the deviants basically
vacating or moving away from worshipping
celestials as a whole and worshipping
the dreaming celestial which they
actually managed to bring back now
following that it just kind of sort of
follows tiamou's own individual story
which is really really cool but
nonetheless right beyond that any
history involving the deviants in marvel
comics is largely crow's history right
it's the the history of his individual
characters because the race of deviance
as a whole doesn't really have a whole
lot to give there as far as marvel is
concerned there's a race that was
created by the celestial somewhere along
the line they fought the the eternals
for a while they conquered the world and
then the celestial showed up wiped out
most of them and they've basically been
underground ever since that's it that's
all you really get in mobile comics
well with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you guys for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace